from robert zemeckis the director of
some of your favorite movies and lots of
creepy animation comes the 20th
anniversary of the film that spawned a
thousand folksy catchphrases life with
lack a box of chocolates and one really
disgusting seafood restaurant Forrest
Gump relive the heartwarming tale of
Forrest a simpleton who bombards
complete strangers with his entire life
story I've won lots of shoes and Jenny a
suicidal junkie hobo experienced the
epic love story between this damaged
woman and the mentally challenged war
hero she manipulates whether it's
sending mixed messages I'll always be
you go boys you stay away from me okay
you just stay away from me please
hitting it and quitting it or hiding his
own child from him for five years until
she has full-blown AIDS and has nowhere
else to go Jenny came back and stayed
with me maybe it was because she had
nowhere else to go together their
one-sided relationship will serve as
cliffnotes to 40 years of whitewashed
American history
utilizing brilliant visual effects and
terrible overdubbing congratulation how
do you PU oh that must be si I'll have
my people take her before it's easy if
you try dick witness Forrest become a
star college football player win the
Medal of Honor play world-class
ping-pong in communist China start a
cross-country running car and build a
multi-million dollar seafood Empire yet
still never get recognized are you
telling me you're the owner of the Bubba
Gump shrimp corporation yes not even by
the news Forrest Gump the gardener from
Greenbow Alabama is about to cross the
Mississippi River again today follow
along with a handful of human cliches
that help Forrest along his way like the
strong-willed single mother the dumb
southerner
and the Vietnam vet with a chip on his
shoulder who teaches all that you can
succeed in America if you're dumb enough
to blindly do whatever other people tell
you to do don't try to be brave you just
run okay
how would you like to go into the
shrimping business with me okay you're
good man good all right gotta try out my
sea legs that's where we're gonna find
those shrimp come on so lace up your
Nikes and pop open a dr. pepper to
revisit all the classic Gump stuff like
feathers shrimp shrimp soup France to
France silent dead celebrities somebody
shot somebody's shot that nice young
president somebody saw his little
brother two boxes of chocolate I saw
Jenny Lieutenant Dan dad ice cream
Lieutenant Dan with legs Lieutenant Dan
without legs you ain't got no legs
through Kenny day things mama said mama
said they'd take me anywhere this moment
you probably didn't understand as a kid
Oh
and lots and lots of running
starring young Claire underwood Baba
Booey Sally Field now garry's nice icy
dump eagle and you same dolt forest gum
if you're ever a shrimp boat captain
that's a day I'm an astronaut and
Lieutenant Dan kept his word the end be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers come find me when you wake up I
have a pair of pantaloons for you to
wear they're stylish hey who farted Gary
bow-chicka-wow-wow